bon moi je fonce à l'aéroport récupérer
l'oncle sam on sait qu'ils sont grands
oncles paternels un unijambiste séibou
fauteuil appartient à l'aéroport et
d'autres n'ont plus besoin que lui ont
plus besoin que l'homme qui est assis là
enfin qu'il n'y avait rien que je joue
[Musique]
la nuit a été bonne docteur jusque celle
d'hier mois que celle de demain alors en
tant que père du jeune marié vous auriez
une seconde réaliser que c'est dans cinq
jours maintenant je vais tout gérer à
leur tour ou le vous en faites pas je
suis vraiment touché que vous vous soyez
déplacer très bien alors j'espère que
vous adorerez l'hôtel
elle va se marier à quoi les pilotes
grippe 4 à darche qui a deux diamants la
pièce montée va se faire humilier par
malraux ce bar will magicien j'ai jamais
giflée mais en forte à c'est un des
avantages à avoir un père qui est absent
[Musique]
vous disiez de vous appeler si on avait
un problème
la fuite est en train de se répandre
toutes vos chambres sont prises pourquoi
vous rigolez on est parti est ce que
vous avez toujours envie de faire partie
de cette grande famille que c'est réglé
c'est tranche que personnes dorment ici
toute l affaire d amiante et sinon
quelques heures ya aucun souci mais pas
toute une équipe non si on en abuse et
risquer un peu il ya aucun danger
il faut qu'on s'en sorte qu'on se sorte
de ce mariage au rabais qu on oublie les
bouteilles pour géant
laissez-moi offrir autre chose aux
enfants comme tous les pères je rêve
d'arriver à offrir un magnifique mariage
à ma fille j'ai dit jonathan mesure
d'aider mes enfants en tout cas quoi
qu'il se passe en tête 12 bon garçon
alors surtout pour un mariage il faut
que ça continue
il ya forcément un hôtel de dispo dans
manhattan je croyais pourtant avoir été
clair mon vieux à au fait j'ai dit que
je gérais alors non j'ai bloqué le plaza
où tout annuler merci encore des
fantastiques
j'ai pas du tout cette voie là non pas
tout le temps mais des fois oui ok on
sourit je serai bien que vous vous
repreniez j'y suis cette fois c'est
passé
[Musique]